- Yeti look at the camera, you look drunk!
- [Woman] Yeti, Yeti, hi!
(upbeat music)
♫ Dog in the house
- I'm Victoria Bech and
this is Albert Einstein
and we are at the D.O.G Pet
Boutique here in Beverly Hills.
The D.O.G Pet Boutique is a full
concierge service for your dog.
We have the best day club for dogs.
- My name is Erin and my
dog's name is Yeti Spaghetti.
Yeti was actually found on the street.
Yeti's every day style is just
a small bandana like this one.
She'll wear Halloween outfits
like weird eyeball goggles.
I'm kind of nervous about how
Yeti's going to get styled.
We're kind of simple,
outdoor kind of people.
- My name is Alyx and this is Jaxon.
Jaxon is a pain in the butt,
that's his personality.
He's hyper, he's action Jaxon.
I try to dress him festive if we're ever
going to a function or a party I try
to match him to the occasion.
I'm hoping that the stylist
really captures his personality.
I would like to see Jaxon in
something that really exonify
California cool, that's always been
my dream to see him on a surfboard.
- My name is Monica and
this is my dog Lucille Ball.
I met Lucy five years ago.
She was actually a rescue.
I don't go crazy with the outfits.
I want Lucy's outfit to like be like
my matching accessory.
I want a full ensemble.
Decked out, looking glam.
(upbeat music)
- For Yeti, I picked out
a more tomboyish look.
I picked out this camo luxe dress.
It's still girly without
being over the top.
For Jaxon, he's very Cali living beachy.
I picked this little cute tank
top with these swim trunks
where the butt is still hanging out.
So for Lucy I wanted to
bring out her inner Beyonce.
I picked this super cute dress
and on top, it's going to put this
little leopard fur jacket.
To finish it off, some pearl necklaces.
Hottest boy on the beach, Jaxon!
Come on!
(cheering)
(camera snapping)
(upbeat music)
- There's a little bit of nip slip,
so she might be uncomfortable
on a hiking trail.
I think she would rather run free
and just show of this necklace bling.
- I think she's a star.
She like really found
her look in this process.
I was wanting Beyonce and I got like
Audrey Hepburn meets Beyonce.
- It's exactly what I
wanted him to look like.
Nautical, beachy, California.
He's so ready to hit a wave.
- [Erin] Take this thing
off me and let me run free!
- [Monica] This is very
sophisticated and very sexy.
(laughs)
- [Alyx] I feel totally cool,
like I'm ready to hit a wave.